[Music]
and I was so honored to be a presenter
here at the MGM Grand Hotel for the ACMs
and the night was all about emotion and
that included from miss Underwood who
made her first appearance since a freak
accident caused her to get nearly 50
stitches on her face after her
triumphant return to the stage
Carrie was overwhelmed by a standing
ovation that lasted over a minute
joso one vocal event of the year with
Keith Urban I'm still kind of what did
you think when you saw her out there
performing I'm very proud of Carrie
she's going through a lot and I am proud
that she's back on the stage again she's
a tremendous vocalist incredible
there were months of buildup to Kerry's
performance the singer took a fall at
home last November resulting in a broken
wrist and a facial injury that required
nearly 50 stitches she told her fans she
quote wasn't looking the same and posted
only limited images of herself while
fans were relieved last night to see her
well there were no visible signs of
caries injuries and another emotional
first Jason Aldean Entertainer of the
Year Jason Aldean performed for the
first time in Las Vegas sets that mass
shooting during a festival six months
ago he was still shaking when we spoke
to him exclusively backstage look at
just being back here I mean it's been an
emotional thing for us the whole weekend
Aldi was part of a star-studded Vega
strong tribute which opened the show
people reached out to us a lot you know
over the last six months and it's meant
the world to us
[Music]
[Applause]